it is time for drew's news bringing you
that good news pill straight from
capitol hill
and with me at the desk co-president of
this tiny news nation it's rossi ross
matthew hello
hello
everybody
okay
this season we're taking our new show on
the road and today
it is beyond an honor to be in our
nation's capital washington dc
ross did you ever think that we would be
reporting from the mall the lincoln
memorial never in a million years this
is crazy but hello dc hello
amazing
all right let's get to our first news
story first up the white house is just
down the road and while so many
presidents have come and gone decorated
and redecorated they all did agree on
one thing a home is not a home without a
fluffy thing in it and presidents are
just like us they love their pets ross
you love your doggies hello i have three
of them that's right and i have two and
the new york times did a deep dive on
first pets throughout white house
history lincoln himself had dogs cats
and a pair of goat brothers what and a
turkey oh because you just throw the
turkey in
[Laughter]
albie jay was smitten with his little
mutt yuki who sat on his lap when he
signed bills i love that i know me too
good luck
good omen and in fact 31 out of 46
presidents had dogs but that's just the
tip of the pet iceberg
taft had a cow named pauline and she
grazed the south lawn and provided fresh
milk and butter this is
utterly fascinating
no not with the otters i can't help it
it's where my mind goes you're milking
it for all it's worth i always am
this one i really liked fun fact
coolidge had a raccoon named rebecca who
was meant to be thanksgiving dinner but
became bffs with the first lady just in
time by the way raccoon
for dinner
thanksgiving jfk had a pony named
macaroni and woodrow wilson kept the
lawn trim and tidy with a soft and
fluffy flocco sheep
in a ross matthews white house who would
be your menagerie uh hello the first
chihuahua the second chihuahua and the
third chihuahua
i feel like they kind of already are
that you know what they're treated like
that i i that's true i know well next
we've got a little taste of dc in food
news
[Applause]
we've got a legendary dc dish that's
been prepared the same way for 63 years
so you know they are doing it right it's
the delicious chili from ben's chili
bowl and this family business is run by
the ali family and they've kept their
chili recipe secret since 1958 that's
what i call secret service yeah they've
served it to everyone from duke
ellington barack obama even martin
luther king jr and we have some right
here now they're serving us look drew
chilly
i'm so excited and we love chili ready
oh my god all right i see you ben this
is good
yeah
o
m
g
oh my gosh i wish i could share with you
but that's like not allowed sorry oh my
gosh this is the best chili i've ever
had yum
okay
next since we're in dc rossi we must
discuss some of the biggest issues
facing our nation it's time to tackle
some topics just a notch down from hot
in a segment we like to call warm topic
we're not controversial
just nice and warm yeah let's kick it
off with warm topic number one the wall
street journal reports you know the
smiley face emoji uh yeah okay well it's
causing some generational debate because
older people think the smiley emoji is
just a smiley emoji but jen's ears some
are saying they see it as sarcastic even
passive aggressive like when they send
it to you they're not really sending you
a smiley face they're sending you this
and it's really sent me into a spiral
because all these times i'm thinking
people are sending me a smiley face
they're really rolling their eyes at me
gosh this is what the young people call
chugi like it's just so over already you
know all right the smiley face is
apparently chuggy
i don't think there's anything to
misinterpret here it's a smiley face you
know everything in life is getting so
sensitive it's like we're just you know
now it's the smiley face emoji we have
to worry about it what's what next just
keep it simple even if you're rolling
your eyes at me i'm going to think it's
a smiley face don't send me a smiley
face and be passive aggressive you just
give it to me good
okay that's a promise
all right warm topic number two the
washington post reports that despite the
workplace moving to zoom co-workers are
still hooking up like crazy
yes
50 of workers say they currently have an
office crush and 25 started or continued
in office romance this year even despite
zoom so do i got to know when it comes
to workplace hoochie coochie are you for
it or against it i am for it you know
i've dipped my pen in the company inc a
time or two what well you know what
here's the thing how many of you spend
almost as much time at work as you do
with your friends and family yeah
you know um
i have fallen in love at work i'm not
alone look at how many actors have met
on a film and fallen in love i mean yes
i think a lot of co-workers in an office
kids at high school when you are
confined together this is what happens
you get to know each other and i always
hope that it's through getting to know
someone that you really fall in love
with them
rather than just looks because you
should fall in love from the inside out
i think it's more everlasting so you
know maybe those hot hook-ups that are
all about physical attraction those may
be a little worrisome in the workplace
um but then i also think it's kind of
like it was fun it was surface move on
you know
i hear you and i think if you find the
one and there's that thing going on you
should do everything in your power to
make it happen including finding another
job because
because i think
if that's all happening in the workplace
it's super uncomfy for everybody else
you work with so if it's just a flaying
fine but if it's something more you just
have to make it work in real life and i
don't think that's a long-term solution
i also think if you do take the risk of
a work romance you have got to be an
adult about what happens if it doesn't
work out yeah and that's kind of on you
yeah well actually it's on you because
you're the one that would do this
and i have
um and who knows it could happen again
ross you're coming over to my side
i'm gonna have more of this chili and
think about it
i would say this um
any girl man anyone on the planet would
be lucky to be with you ah
true it's true samesies i love you i
love you more
[Music]